and being a conservative on the south
side of chicago
is not
an easy thing to do
especially when you are
a black
pastor
preacher in the community
[Music]
can you believe it i'm still here that's
right living inside this tent from
november 20th to february 28th bringing
to you the awareness that you need to
know about the violence in chicago but
also to raise as much money as we
possibly can to build a center here on
this block that is much needed called oh
block it's called oh block because it's
named after a young man who was shot and
killed the gangs took the o in his name
after od perry
and begin to call it o block well we
decided we're going to keep the o but
we're going to change it to opportunity
block i want to thank fox for giving me
the opportunity every single day to
bring to you rooftop revelations where i
share with you my viewpoints thoughts
and opinions as it relates to what's
going on in chicago but also around our
great country
i get a lot of text messages and emails
and questions
surrounding
a question that has
come at me so many times
and the question is
how did you become a conservative
[Music]
and i always tell the same story how i
was at ball state university majoring in
political science and i never will
forget
it was a political science 101 class my
first political science class
where the professor put a bunch of
viewpoints on the on the board
on one side he had
views of conservatives on one side he
had views of liberals but you didn't
know that because he had them covered up
and they were switched
the conservative views were on the right
the i mean the liberal views were on the
right and the conservative reviews were
on the left
but we didn't know that because they
were covered
and he began to go down the list
and he said circle the ones or write the
ones that you agree with
and after going through the list of
thoughts and views
he uncovered the words
and there they were conservative
liberal
and when i looked at it i discovered
that
for the first time i understood that my
views were more more aligned to being a
conservative
but then the professor went on after
little dialogue and discussion of the
views and he said
if you are conservative
and you hold these viewpoints it is most
likely
that you align with the republican party
whoa
if you hold these viewpoints is more
likely
the liberal viewpoints you're aligned
with the democratic party
and for the first time ever
i was challenged
with being a democrat
because after all i had been taught all
of my life and i had seen it in my home
and
that that blacks are democrats and
that's just the way that it is
but after looking at that board and
staring it set me on a path
to try and discover
what i really believe
not what
they were forcing upon me or not what
they were trying to demand for me to
believe
but what
at my core in my heart
what did i really believe
and i discovered
after four years of
college at ball state university
where i got a degree in political
science
i discovered
i'm conservative
but that discovery let me tell you
has come with a lot of heartache and a
lot of pain
because see
here i am years later
on the south side of chicago
and being a conservative on the south
side of chicago
is not
an easy thing to do
especially when you are a black
pastor
preacher
in the community
i could tell you on and on about so many
things
that have happened to me just because
i've declared
i'm a conservative
just because i said i vote
republican
you wouldn't believe it but let me tell
you
i've been
threatened so many times
do you know that
the union's even picketed my church and
my house where i live
do you know that there was a governor
that i endorsed
uh he eventually won the republican
governor bruce rauner
and when i endorsed him do you know that
my family
was threatened so much that
they had to move us
to a place
just to hide
to protect my family
because of all the death threats
[Music]
being a conservative
[Music]
has had a great price
[Music]
do you not know that
because i decided to say i'm a
conservative and i'm a republican
and i'm not going to budge on it
i lost
three-fourths of my congregation
i lost three-fourths of our budget
just because i said i'm going to
be conservative
that i hold conservative values
but here's a heartbreaking thing
do you not know that most blacks
hold conservative values
[Music]
but we have been so indoctrinated
to believe that we most
that we must
vote democrat there is no other way
[Music]
i'm hoping and praying
that
my example of being steadfast
[Music]
and showing people that you can
be different
that you don't have to abide by the
status quo
i'm praying that it will show people
that you can stand on what you believe
so
here i am on this rooftop
a conservative
black preacher
on the south side of chicago
trying to do the very best that i can
possibly do
for the people in our community
for the people in chicago
and for our great country
and for that
i don't believe i have anything to be
ashamed of
as i always say god bless you
god bless america
and thank you for tuning in to rooftop
revelations
until tomorrow
peace
you